what do you think right now is the
fastest way to get to your first
$100,000 by not liking the word fast I'm
really scared of that word attention is
the number one
asset to actually answer you literally
the fastest way to get there is through
self-awareness understanding what you're
actually good at you might be good at
sales you might be good at operations
you might be good at knowing everything
about the Marvel Universe and that is
actually your gateway to get there
fastest cuz it's through content or
flipping stuff on eBay and stuff of that
nature so I think people try to chase
Trends real estate crypto cannabis AI
they're just constantly looking at these
Trends CU they see them as things that
will get them there fast and I actually
think that those are the things that are
most guaranteed to not get you
there